[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Montag Rudi Zahn ist auch wieder
dabei für den Sport hallo schönen guten
Abend und das sind die Themen von heute
ultra Rechte gewinnen italien-wahl
Georgia Meloni und ihr rechtsbündnis
erreichen in beiden Kammern die Mehrheit
kommt sie noch und wenn ja für wie lange
um die geplante gasumlage und
Alternativen wird weiter gestritten auch
innerhalb der Koalition
Widerstand gegen Zwangsrekrutierung
immer mehr Russen wären sich gegen einen
Kriegseinsatz oder fliehen aus dem Land
ein historisches Wahlergebnis in Italien
die drittgrößte Wirtschaftsmacht Europas
rückt politisch so weit nach rechts wie
noch nie seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg mit
noch ungewissen Folgen für Europa und
die Wahlbeteiligung war noch nie so
gering große Gewinnerin ist Georgia
Meloni ihre
parteifratelli d'Italia gewinnt rund ein
Viertel der Stimmen zusammen mit der
leger von Matteo Salvini und der Forza
Italia von Silvio Berlusconi reicht es
für eine Mehrheit Meloni wäre die erste
Frau an der Spitze der italienischen
Regierung aus Rom Annette hilsenbeck es
sieht so aus wie immer in Rom um die
Mittagszeit und doch hat sich etwas
verändert Italien hat gewählt und wird
eine rechte Regierung bekommen wir
hoffen dass diese Regierung insgesamt
Dinge besser macht sie sind gewillt
worden da kann man nichts gegen machen
leider
sie steht schon nachts als Siegerin fest
Georgia miloni holte mit ihrer
rechtsradikalen fratelli die Thalia die
stärkste Partei geworden ist über 26
Prozent Meloni wird wohl
Ministerpräsidentin und gibt sich
bereits staatstragend
wenn wir ein Teil der Geschichte werden
wollen müssen wir verstehen dass wir
eine Verantwortung haben gegenüber
Millionen von Menschen denn Italien hat
uns gewählt und wir werden sie nicht
betrügen
es ist ein Rechtsruck melonis fratelli
d'Italia gilt als nationalkonservativ
mit faschistischen Wurzeln mit ihren
Bündnispartnern expremier Berlusconi mit
seiner rechtskonservativen Forza Italia
um Matteo salvinis rechtspopulistischer
leger hat sie eine klare Mehrheit
zunächst einmal glaube ich dass die
Italiener eine antihistablishment-stimme
abgeben wollten und der Großteil derer
die für Georgia Meloni gestimmt haben
stellt nicht allzu viele Fragen darüber
wofür Georgia Meloni steht
die sozialdemokratische PD wurde
zweitstärkste Partei hatte es aber vor
der Wahl nicht geschafft eine große
Mitte links-allianz zu schmieden
wir werden jetzt in die Opposition gehen
mit großer Entschlossenheit die PD wird
nicht zulassen dass Italien aus dem
Herzen Europas verschwindet
mehr als ein Drittel der Wähler ist gar
nicht zur Urne gegangen die
Wahlbeteiligung war mit 63,9% historisch
niedrig
Andreas Postel in Rom was ist von
Georgia Meloni zu erwarten
wenn sie als Ministerpräsidentin hier in
Italien gewählt wird dann wird sie in
erster Linie sicherlich ihre national
faschistische Kernklientel bedienen
müssen und Themen wie Migration
Familienpolitik sicherlich eine härtere
Gangart einschlagen und auf der anderen
Seite hat sie im Wahlkampf moderate Töne
angespielt und hat eindeutig gesagt sie
stehe zum transatlantischen
Bündnissystem zu den EU-Sanktionen gegen
Russland Georgia Meloni wird also
insgesamt hier zwei Gesichter zeigen man
weiß jetzt noch nicht genau in welche
Richtungen sich das entwickelt eines ist
jedenfalls klar die Inspiration die ihr
Wahlsieg allein für die europäische
Rechte bedeutet hat und die die
45-Jährige Römerin hier entfaltet Alissa
jung stellt sie uns kurz vor
extrem erfolgreich und extrem rechts das
ist Georgia Meloni in den letzten Jahren
ist sie an allen Männern vorbeigezogen
und das Gesicht der rechten in Italien
geworden
[Applaus]
ich bin Georgia eine Frau eine Mutter
eine Italienerin eine Christin was sie
will die sogenannte traditionelle
Familie Frauen von Abtreibungen
abbringen Meloni ist nationalistisch
will Italien gegen Migration abschotten
Nationen existieren nur wenn sie Grenzen
haben diese Grenzen muss man verteidigen
man reist nicht illegale in Italien ein
sie will ein starkes international
respektiertes Italien
Meloni ist dafür die Ukraine im Kampf
gegen Russland zu unterstützen fordert
gleichzeitig
ein vom Besten finanzierter
Entschädigungsfonds zu Unterstützung der
von Sanktionen am stärksten betroffenen
Länder
kein Nein zu Europa aber Italien zuerst
das könnte Meloni zur ersten
Ministerpräsidentin Italiens machen
auch eine Regierung Meloni hätte kaum
Handlungsspielraum für größere
versprechen Italien ist dringend
angewiesen auf Milliarden Hilfsfonds aus
der Europäischen Union aus Brüssel und
diesen an konkreter reformvorgaben
geknüpft und auch die an die müsste sich
auch eine Regierung Meloni halten
die Einschätzung live aus Rom Dankeschön
Andreas Postel
in Deutschland und Europa reagieren
viele besorgt auf diesen Wahlausgang als
benachbarte und befreundete Länder
müssen wir weiter zusammenarbeiten sagt
Frankreichs Präsident macron Jubel
dagegen bei Europas rechten Parteien
Bravo Georgia applaudiert Ungarns
Ministerpräsident Orban die AFD schickt
herzliche Glückwünsche Frankreichs
Marine Le Pen spricht von einem großen
Sieg fragen wir nach in Brüssel bei
Gunnar Krüger was kommt da auf Europa zu
ja wenn man sich die Liste der
Gratulanten anschaut dann sieht man da
verschiebt sich etwas und zwar für alle
EU-Institutionen im EU-Parlament da
könnte es einen neuen Versuch geben am
rechten Rand eine neue dann
drittstärkste Fraktion zu bilden im Rat
der Mitgliedsstaaten da könnte es neue
Koalitionen geben Italien könnte in
Zukunft vielleicht seltener mit
Südeuropa und viel häufiger mit
Osteuropa abstimmen und für die
EU-Kommission da gibt es einen neuen
Störenfried und gleich bei drei
drängenden Themen die
migrationspolitiker eine neue gemeinsame
Migrationspolitik die dürfte ein
Hardliner ein Hardliner Salvini wohl
verhindern genauso neue härtere
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland die dürfte
der putinfreund bellosconi verhindern
das größte Problem aber könnte
vielleicht Meloni und Maastricht heißen
Meloni möchte mehr Schulden möchte mehr
Ausgaben manche sorgen sich da über vor
einer neuen Euro-Krise die EU hat aber
auch mit dagegen die Kommission kann die
Haushalte der Mitgliedstaaten also auch
den von Italien überwachen die
Kommission hat auch schon angekündigt
dass sie bei den harten Kriterien für
die Auszahlung der
corona-hilfsmilliarden bleiben möchte
und sie hat eine starke Verbündete die
Europäische Zentralbank die nur dann
weiterhin italienische Anleihen kaufen
will wenn dort Haushaltsdisziplin
herrscht also auch für wahlsiegerinnen
gibt es nur begrenzte Spielräume und
Spielregeln macht großenteils die EU
aber sie muss sie dann auch durchsetzen
Dankeschön nach Brüssel
Rechtsruck in Italien wohin steuert
Europa das fragt auch ein
zdf-spezialdirekt nach uns und wie die
Regierungsbildung in den kommenden
Wochen abläuft haben wir für Sie in der
ZDF heute-
der Bundeskanzler ist positiv auf Corona
getestet worden er habe milde Symptome
und sei in Isolation in der
kanzlerwohnung im Bunde im
Bundeskanzleramt heißt es währenddessen
steht ein von Anfang an umstrittenes
Regierungsprojekt vor dem Aus die
gasumlage eigentlich will sie keiner
mehr die Frage ist jetzt wie schnell ist
sie zu stoppen aus Berlin berichtet
Daniel putzen
für Verbraucher ist es nicht leicht den
Überblick zu behalten bei der gasumlage
letzte Woche noch ereiferte sich der
Wirtschaftsminister über Kritik wie
folgt
das wie Gasanlage muss weg sind wir denn
hier im Fußballstadion oder was ist das
mit Demo muss weg sie sind die muss weg
auf Position heute nun stimmt sein
Parteichef in den muss Vektor ein wenn
auch anders im Ton das die jetzt weg
muss ist etwas was richtig ist das sehen
alle so aber das ist nicht von heute auf
morgen gehen nach all den Vorbereitungen
ist auch auf der anderen Seite
verständlich gelingt die Rückabwicklung
nicht in dieser Woche kommt die Umlage
trotzdem wie geplant zum ersten Oktober
fällig würde sie für Verbraucher aber
erst Ende Oktober insofern bliebe für
die Korrektur noch etwas mehr Zeit
schlussendlich darf keine Mehrbelastung
der Privathaushalte über den Weg einer
Umlage geschehen wenn sowas im
Zweifelsfall über eine Rückerstattung
oder ähnliches ausgeglichen werden muss
muss man sich das angucken wichtig ist
dass die Bundesregierung gezeigt hat
dass sie in der Lage ist einen Fehler
auch zu erkennen und dann als solchen am
Ende auch zu korrigieren das passiert
jetzt gerade als Alternative wird nun
eine gaspreisbremse gehandelt die in der
es kein Geld bringen sondern
zusätzliches kosten würde konkrete Ideen
hierzu nach wie vor nicht spruchreif ich
halte daran fest dass ich öffentlich
nicht einzelne Instrumente nenne
sondern Ihnen dann das präsentiere auf
was wir uns innerhalb der
Bundesregierung verständigt haben zu
wenig zu spät sagt die Opposition wenn
Lindner sagt der soll eine Preisbremse
kommen da ist es gut aber die brauchen
wir jetzt er muss jetzt Vorschläge
machen er muss jetzt vortragen was das
kosten würde wie es ja nach seiner
Auffassung tatsächlich auch in Einklang
steht mit der Schuldenbremse eine jüngst
eingerichtete Kommission soll die
geplante gaspreisbremse ausgestalten
diese Kommission habe getagt und sehr
gut gearbeitet so heute ein
Regierungssprecher Details wurden nicht
bekannt
die Regierung gibt da gerade kein gutes
Bild abteo Koll oder das kann man wohl
sagen also ich glaube für die gasumlage
gäbe es handwerklich wieder ein Meister
noch ein Gesellenbrief die
ampelregierung hat mit diesem
politischen Werkstück ja etwas
geschaffen dessen Ende offensichtlich
schon vor dem Anfang besiegelt scheint
wobei das Absurde ja passieren könnte
dass die gasumlage am Samstag also am 1
oktober in Kraft tritt aber als eine Art
lebende polit-tote die keinen Bestand
hat und bald durch etwas anderes wie
beispielsweise die gaspreisbremse dann
ersetzt wird im Moment wird
offensichtlich hinter den Kulissen
ordentlich an einer Alternative
gearbeitet und im Prinzip geht es darum
wie man die vielen Milliarden die die
Umlage ja gebracht hätte ersetzen kann
wobei der Finanzminister noch an der
Schuldenbremse festhält und zwar nicht
nur weil sie ein wichtiger Teil seiner
ftp-programmatik ist sondern weil er
fürchtet dass er ohne sie die sonstigen
Wünsche für mehr Ausgaben dann nicht
mehr abwehren kann daher auch ja sein
Wort vom finanzpolitischen Dammbruch
fazit Die Gas Anlage stirbt gerade die
ersatzfinanzierung ist aber noch nicht
in der Welt Dankeschön nach Berlin
teopol
nach Russland sie wollen nicht in den
Krieg tausende Männer versuchen das Land
zu verlassen um der teilmobilisierung zu
entgehen das Schließen von Grenzen sei
nicht undenkbar sagt heute kremesprecher
peskov und räumt gleichzeitig Fehler bei
Einberufungen ein im ganzen Land wächst
der Widerstand Nena kuscheln
kein Krieg kein Krieg rufen diese Frauen
in Dagestan im Süden Russlands die Wut
wächst in einem der ärmsten Teile des
Landes warum holt ihr unsere Männer und
Kinder Weg fragen Sie diesen Polizisten
ausgerechnet hier wo sie schon viele
Söhne Väter Ehemänner in dem Krieg
verloren haben die Staatsmacht greift
hart durch es gibt dutzende Festnahmen
wie angespannt die Stimmung in Russland
ist zeigt auch folgendes Video
in einer einberufungsstelle in
Ostsibirien schießt ein Reservist er
soll offenbaren die Front anderswo
versucht sich ein junger Mann aus
Protest selbst anzuzünden er wird
abgeführt und dann gibt es die die ihre
einzige Chance nur noch in der Flucht
sehen in Sicherheit dann finden sie
deutliche Worte
wir sind absolut gegen diesen Krieg und
wir nennen ihn so wie er ist es ist
keine Operation es ist ein Krieg den
Russland auf dem Territorium der Ukraine
führt in den besetzten Gebieten der
Ostukraine laufen die sogenannten
Referenten zum Anschluss an Russland
hier in Melli Topol fürchten sie gar
dass auch Ukrainer für den russischen
Kriegsdienst einberufen werden könnten
es wurde eine Last ausgegeben bis zum
10.10 sollen 3000 Männer unserer Stadt
rekrutiert werden es ist vor uns klar
dass das nicht freiwillig passieren wird
sie werden vorsätzlich die Leute dazu
zwingen gegen das eigene ukrainische
Volk in den Krieg zu ziehen
Männer zwischen 18 und 63 Jahren dürfen
die Stadt wohl nicht mehr verlassen bis
morgen noch laufen die Referenten
bereits am Donnerstag könnte sich das
russische Unterhaus die Duma schon mit
der Annexion beschäftigen
in die Stadt Ischewsk in Zentralrussland
dort hat ein bewaffneter in einer Schule
15 Menschen getötet und mehr als 20
verletzt die meisten von ihnen Kinder
der kremme stuft die Tat als
Terrorangriff eines Rechtsextremisten
ein regionalen Behörden zufolge bei der
Täter ein ehemaliger Schüler mit
psychischen Problemen er habe sich nach
dem Angriff selbst getötet
zurück nach Deutschland die katholische
Kirche tut sich schwer mit Veränderung
so gibt es hier eine ganze Reihe
engagierter Laien und Bischöfe doch die
werden immer wieder ausgebremst sowohl
aus Rom als auch aus den eigenen Reihen
zum Auftakt der Herbstvollversammlung
der Bischofskonferenz ließ deren
Vorsitzender betzing heute wissen wir
werden uns durch die Blockierer nicht
aufhalten lassen enken Klinge
ruhig wirkt es rund um den Dom in Fulda
doch es sind umstrittene Themen zu
besprechen durch konservative Bischöfe
scheiterte beim letzten Treffen des
Reformprozesses synodaler Weg ein
grundlegendes Papier zu einer
veränderten katholischen Sexualmoral die
Bischofskonferenz wirkt gespalten
wir sind in Positionen wirklich
different jeder muss sich am eigenen
Schopf greifen und sagen wo kann ich
denn auf andere zugehen und immer nur
Nein stimmen es sicher nicht der
richtige Weg eine deutliche Mehrheit der
Bischöfe sei aber für Reformen betonte
der Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz auch unter den
Gläubigen zwei Lager eine kleine Gruppe
demonstriert vor der Tür gegen
Veränderungen in der katholischen Kirche
für andere müssten Reformen viel
schneller umgesetzt werden am Wochenende
in Köln forderten rund 30 katholische
Verbände und Initiativen mehr
Mitbestimmung auch von Frauen
es muss mit dem Reformprozess
weitergehen und wir dürfen nicht locker
lassen wir müssen einen gewissen Druck
ausüben die sexualisierte Gewalt in der
katholischen Kirche ist noch nicht
aufgearbeitet aber wenn die Bischöfe
nicht endlich jetzt einen gemeinsamen
Weg finden dann wird der
Bedeutungsverlust der
römisch-katholischen Kirche hier in
Deutschland und auch weltweit weiter
voranschreiten das Thema Missbrauch auch
ein Schwerpunkt der Beratungen und der
in Kürze anstehende Besuch der Bischöfe
im Vatikan wo man den deutschen
Reformprozess kritisch sieht bis
Donnerstag wird getagt
klimaschonend bauen wie das gelingen
kann war heute Thema bei der
Jahreskonferenz des Rats für nachhaltige
Entwicklung
ein Problem bisher der Zement im Beton
die Herstellung verursacht gut acht
Prozent der globalen CO2-Emissionen pro
Jahr die Alternative Bauen mit Holz das
ist langlebig wächst nach lässt sich
klimaneutral entsorgen und ist dazu noch
ein CO2-Speicher Dorothea Dörner hat
mehr
als eine Böhringer mit ihrer Familie
nach Freiburg in den Öko und
vorzeigestadtteil gezogen ist waren sie
Vorreiter in Sachen nachhaltigem Bauen
zusammen mit einer Baugruppe errichteten
sie ein niedrig Energiehaus aus Holz wir
wohnen neben 16 Jahre hier schon drin
und wir freuen uns auch wirklich dass es
tatsächlich so ist dass wir sehr wenig
Energie brauchen um hier warm zu haben
bauen mit Holz war bisher für allem für
Besserverdiener erschwinglich jetzt soll
es auch für untere Einkommensschichten
finanzierbar sein ein Beispiel dafür der
geplante Freiburger Stadtteil dietenbach
Rüdiger Engel ist von Anfang an dabei
und koordiniert das Projekt 10% teurer
ist das Bauen mit Holz das soll durch
zahlreiche Subventionen ausgeglichen
werden und es gibt weitere Anreize wenn
sich jemand mit einem Holzbau Projekt
bewirbt hat er größere Chancen ein
Grundstück zu erhalten als in einer
konventionellen Bauweise das Ziel in
dietenbach sollen von den rund 7000
Wohnungen und Häusern bis zu 50% in
nachhaltiger Bauweise errichtet ein
weiteres kleines Freiburger Projekt in
Holzbauweise steht bereits der
schildacker Oberbürgermeister Martin
Horn sieht darin die Zukunft vom
Wohnungsbau gerade wenn wir über
Ökologie Klimaschutz unbezahlbares
wohnreden dann muss das perspektivisch
viel stärker über Holz gehen und diese
116 Wohnungen sind deswegen nur der
Anfang 16.000 Menschen sollen in
dietenbach mal wohnen bis der neue
Stadtteil aber endgültig fertig ist
werden doch mindestens 25 Jahre vergehen
stand jetzt ein bisschen lange da haben
wir doch mal schön sehen können das
Modell Fußball spannender Abend heute ja
das DFB-Team ist wieder gefordert am
Abend tritt die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft in der nations
League im legendären Londoner Wembley
Stadion gegen England an nach der
enttäuschenden Niederlage gegen Ungarn
und der damit verpassten Endrunde
erwartet Bundestrainer Hansi Flick von
seinem Team eine deutliche Steigerung
ein junger Spieler soll für frischen
Wind sorgen
sein Spitzname ist Bambi wegen der
Rehaugen Mark harmlos klingen aber Hansi
Flick wittert in Jamal musiala den
torhungrigen Angreifer schon mal wir
spielen hier wemblech da nicht glaube
für ihn auch eine tolle Sache
Veränderung tut Not beim 0:1 gegen WM
nicht Teilnehmer Ungarn wirkte vieles zu
unbeholfen Kreativität und Spielwitz
fehlten ich will immer spielen so das
war es war schon immer meine Einstellung
wenn ich egal wie viele Minuten ich bin
immer hungrig zu spielen den
Bayern-Spielern ist derzeit die
Selbstverständlichkeit des Siegens
abhanden gekommen beim erst 19-jährigen
jamalmusiala könnte die Jugendliche
Unbekümmertheit ein Trumpf sein
die deutschen Volleyballerinnen gewinnen
auch das zweite Spiel bei der
Weltmeisterschaft in Polen und den
Niederlanden nach dem Auftakt Erfolg
gegen Bulgarien Sieg das Team in Arnheim
gegen Kasachstan mühelos mit 3:0
Deutschlands Schmetterlinge fliegen
weiter auf Wolke 7 gegen Außenseiter
Kasachstan in Weiß glänzt vor allem
Jennifer janniska als beste
Punktesammlerin hier ein großartiger
Blog starke 17 Zähler steuert die
Kapitän in Bayern und Zuspielerin Pia
Kästner setzt ihre starken
Angreiferinnen wie Kimberley treffen
neok glänzend in Szene 25 zu 15 25 18
und mit diesem Matchball zum 25 zu 21
machen die deutschen Frauen den klaren
3:0 Erfolg perfekt zweiter Sieg im
zweiten Spiel die WM startet
verheißungsvoll
das war der kurze Sport an diesem Tag
mit starken Frauen
eine herbstlich kühle Woche kommt auf
uns zu mit viel Regen und wenig Sonne
die Details hat gleich Katja horneffer
Christian Sievers freut sich auf Sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn wir
danken für Ihr Interesse und wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine wechselhafte
windige wetterwoche die meiste sonder
der nächsten paar Tage haben wir heute
wohl schon gesehen hier zwischen der
Ostseeküste und dem Alpenrand es waren
kräftige Schauer unterwegs und von
Nordwesten zieht jetzt ein Regenwand
herein und auch dort regnet es kräftig
dieses Regenband sieht im Laufe der
Nacht etwas weiter nach Osten so
zwischen der Ostseeküste und dem
Erzgebirge auch an der Donau bleibt ist
trocken dazu pfeift der Wind Stürme
schier über den Schwarzwaldhöhen und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 5 Grad an
diesen Werten ändert sich morgen über
Tag nur wenig da erwarten uns so acht
bis 14 Grad mit den milderen Werten in
Berlin-Brandenburg im östlichen Sachsen
oder auch am Oberrhein das wird ein
düsterer Dienstag mit viel Regen die
Sonne bekommen wir kaum zu Gesicht und
es kann auch Gewitter geben hier an der
Nordseeküste am Alpenrand singt die
Schneefallgrenze auf 1.500 Meter und
ganz ähnlich wird dann auch der Mittwoch
am Donnerstag gibt es schon etwas der
Sonne und die Temperaturen steigen ein
bisschen am Freitag erwartet uns dann
höchstens noch am Alpenrand Regen bei
Temperaturen von 11 bis 18 Grad damit
wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend